are you dying to see what Project
Scorpio looks like well I'm guessing
you'll see the official console at e3
but if you want to get another look at
its dev kit then your wish is about to
come true I'm Matt and this is your
project Scorpio gamespot news update a
short video showing off the dev kit of
Microsoft's powerful new console was
posted online by Windows Central's Jeff
Gordon it doesn't show anything we
haven't already seen yet but it gives us
a closer look at the whole front of the
system including that display which
features a frames per second counter we
haven't learned much from this video but
make sure to LIKE and subscribe because
we're going to keep you updated on all
of the project Scorpio news the first
public images of the project Scorpio dev
kit were revealed in early April around
the same time the console specs were
detailed project Scorpio is expected to
launch this holiday but Microsoft hasn't
said when it will properly unveil the
actual console Xbox head Phil Spencer is
unsure if we'll see it before June but
you can definitely expect to hear more
at Microsoft's e3 briefing on June 11th
at 2 p.m. Pacific and while you wait for
that why not check out an upcoming Xbox
one game in our video of every super
move from injustice to
[Music]
you